and breaking news here at six o'clock
Metro Police just releasing this video
the suspect they believe is responsible
for a series of Casino robberies so take
a good look at your screen here our 8
news now investigators learning the
series includes that robbery we told you
about at the Rampart Casino on Christmas
Eve police say that man drives a Chevy
Cruze and a Mazda 6 but now they're
telling us both of those cars were
stolen you can see the license plate
information for both of the vehicles
right now on your screen anyone with
information that maybe you recognize
something in that video is asked to call
Crime Stoppers and we do thank you for
joining us here at six I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftis source is telling
our eight news now investigators a
person pulled over earlier today near
Sunset Station not connected to those
Casino robberies Henderson Police made a
traffic stop right near Casino late this
morning sources say Metro came in
believing the person may be connected to
that string of Unsolved robberies police
ended up letting that driver go